how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel kang is
coming to the MCU
that's right kang the conqueror the
master of time travel will be coming to
the MCU as a villain to the avengers and
this really comes at little to no
surprise as kang the conqueror was set
up very well in avengers endgame and for
those of you who are curious
yes Galactus is still coming to be the
main big bad of the MCU along with
Doctor Doom but not before King and some
recent details that we got from Marvel
Studios themselves make it pretty
obvious and if we take a look at some of
the evidence that suggests that Kang is
coming we can see that Marvel Studios
has been planting breadcrumbs for King
to conquer to make his debut for some
time now and the reason that came to
conquer is such a big deal is because he
is directly associated with the
Fantastic Four the Avengers and the
Young Avengers and according to a recent
report came the conquer is going to be
the person that brings the Fantastic
Four and the Avengers together in the
next Avengers film so in this video
we'll talk about this new report that
says Kang the Conqueror is coming talk
about all the ways that Marvel Studios
has been setting him up over time and
what it means for the future of the MCU
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all things relating
to the MCU and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 or giveaway details at the end so
as I mentioned the MCU has already
dropped some hints that Kang is going to
be the next villain but first let's
check out Mikey Sutton's report about
Kang coming to the MCU Mikey originally
leaked this yesterday to the Lords of
the log boxes YouTube channel you can
check them out Timbo's a great guy and
according to their scoop Marvel Studios
is planning on Kang being the next
villain for the next Avengers movie
according to this report Marvel Studios
is still planning on having Galactus and
Doctor Doom be the main big bads of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
but they're going to be built up over
time over the years of phase 4 and phase
5
just like Fanus was and of course there
were villains in-between Ultron and Loki
but it all ultimately led up to Thanos
just like phase 4 and phase 5 are all
going to ultimately lead up to Galactus
and Doctor Doom but before they come
according to Mikey Sutton we're going to
see king of the Conqueror and he's going
to be the villain that unites the
Fantastic Four with the Avengers now we
know that the Fantastic Four are coming
it's already been confirmed to Kevin
Fugazi rd name dropped them at San Diego
comic-con in 2019 so it's only a matter
of time until the new Avengers team
which we will eventually be introduced
to team up with the Fantastic Four and
of course the x-men as well and
according to Mikey Sutton Kang is going
to unite the Fantastic Four and the
Avengers and send them on a futuristic
and historic level sending half of the
team to 2099 and the other half of the
team will be sent back to the Old West
meeting the two gun kid and that's my
key sentence scoop right now according
to him that's being talked about at
Marvel Studios and like I said it's not
really that big of a surprise as Marvel
Studios has dropped a little hints that
Kang is coming Tony Stark and Avengers
endgame dropped a pretty big clue where
he said you messed with time it tends to
mess back well the Avengers definitely
messed with time and they created
multiple alternate realities and there's
one person who really won't be okay with
that and of course that's king if you
thought that Avengers and game had
complicated time travel involved in it
then you're definitely going to think
that came the Conqueror's story is quite
confusing
but I'll do my best to simplify it the
main thing that you need to know about
King to conquer is that he is a time
traveler but time travel for King works
in the exact same way that it worked in
Avengers endgame you see there are
primarily three main types of time
travel one is mutable time travel
now mutable time travel is pretty
straightforward you change something in
the past and it changes the future thank
back to the future where he continues to
look at the photo and watches his family
fade from existence the second type of
time travel is a mutable time travel and
this type of time travel states that
whatever has happened it will always
happen no matter what you do if you go
back in time to prevent your actions it
will only cause your actions to happen
thank Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
Azkaban and Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure and then you have multiple
timelines this is what we saw in
avengers endgame if you change the past
that will only create a new alternate
timeline and this is how time works for
Kang the Conqueror and this is what
Avengers endgame set up you see there
are many different versions of Kang from
many different alternate realities and
timelines and they range from being evil
to being good to even being very young
but at the root of Kang is a connection
to the Fantastic Four and to Doctor Doom
you see Kang's real name is Nathaniel
Richards a descendant of Reed Richards
aka
mr. fantastic although in some comics
they do say that he's a descendant of
Victor Von Doom
aka Doctor Doom but regardless the
connection to the Fantastic Four and
Doctor Doom is still there you see the
original Nathaniel Richards the original
King is from the 31st century so way
into the future and during this time
Nathaniel Richards was a very smart
robotic student however one day a bully
at school would end up slicing his
throat open and he'd have to take a year
off recovering but during this time he
became fascinated with the adventures of
his ancestor Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four particularly their time
traveling
however time travel was actually illegal
in his timeline in the 31st century
however Nathaniel had come across an old
time-traveling device and in secret he
went about restoring it and for the
first time when he is 25 years old he
travels back in time to ancient Egypt
and he dubs himself the Pharaoh Rama Tut
and as the Pharaoh he plans to claim in
Sabah nur who is the mutant that would
go on to become apocalypse as his heir
but ironically enough the Fantastic Four
happened to be doing some time-traveling
themselves and ended up in the exact
same time as Nathaniel Richards in
ancient Egypt the Fantastic Four would
end up defeating Nathanael and Nathanael
being very bitter travels to the 20th
century and there he meets dr. doom he
goes on to design an armor that is based
off of dr. Doom's and he calls himself
the Scarlet centurion and he tries to
get rid of the Avengers by facing them
against their alternate reality
counterparts however the Avengers defeat
him and push him out of their timeline
he then tries to return to the 31st
century but he overshoots it by a
thousand years he finds a war-torn earth
and very easily takes it over he then
manages to leave earth and takes over
most of the galaxy as well calling
himself King the Conqueror and that's
when King is officially born now King
would ultimately travel throughout many
different points and time creating
multiple realities and multiple versions
of himself that exist in different
timelines and this ties into something
very important that Marvel Studios
themselves have just showed us when
Disney and Marvel released the official
trailer for the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier series the one division series
and the Loki series they showed us
something very important when they
showed us the Loki footage they showed
Loki in a prison uniform that said T
a on it and this stands for the time
variance Authority now the time variance
Authority is responsible for protecting
timelines and alternate realities when
they find out that one person or a time
line in general is affecting another
time line it's their job to step in and
prevent that person or timeline from
affecting the other timelines around it
and as you can probably guess by now
King runs into the time variance
Authority however they're not really
that effective at their job and they
fail to stop King they do however manage
to capture the two gunkid at one point
in time and this ties directly into
Mikey Sutton scoop where he says that
the Avengers and the Fantastic Four are
going to be split into two teams one of
which is going to go back in the Old
West and see the two gunkid so
connections are already starting to form
here and another thing is that it is
officially confirmed that the actor Owen
Wilson has been cast for the Loki series
and according to recent reports he's
going to be playing the character
justice peace justice peace is the head
of the time variance Authority and he
has come in contact with King and his
Qing Dynasty many times so it's starting
to become quite clear how Marvel Studios
is planning and already setting up the
introduction of Kang to conquer but
perhaps the most interesting fact about
King to conquer and something that has
already been set up in the MCU is iron
lad and that's because Kang the
Conqueror is actually iron lad iron lad
is the adolescent version of Nathaniel
Richards so iron lad would eventually go
on to become a king the Conqueror you
see Kang the Conqueror the already
villain at the time would go back in
time to see 16 year old Nathaniel
Richards and protect him from the knife
attack from the bullies Kang ving takes
Nathaniel throughout time and shows him
what he becomes in hopes that it would
inspire him but instead it actually
horrifies him and Nathaniel takes the
time-travel device that Kang gave him
and he goes back in time he seeks the
help of the Avengers but he finds out
that they've disbanded much like in our
current timeline right now there are no
Avengers and instead he ends up
recruiting multiple people and he forms
the Young Avengers he then creates a
model of armor based off of Iron Man's
and he calls himself iron lad eventually
King comes to the Past looking for Nate
wanting to return his younger self to
his proper place in the timeline iron
lad refuses because he refuses to become
the future king
so the Young Avengers fight Kang and
eventually iron lad
which of Hawkeye's sword right through
Kings chest killing him however there
are major repercussions including all of
the Avengers being dead and the Young
Avengers Wiccan and hoechlin disappear
as well
iron lad realizes that the only way to
restore everything is to eventually
become king in doing so he realizes that
he will lose all of his memories as his
past self and the Young Avengers
he asked the young Avengers for
forgiveness and he kisses stature before
he leaves and then he goes on to become
King the Conqueror
now stature is Cassie Leng ant-man's
daughter and iron lad has a relationship
with her when he's back in that timeline
now we've already seen a teenager Cassie
Lang and Avengers endgame and at the
funeral of Tony Stark we see Harley
keiner there and for those of you who
may have missed it Harley keiner is the
kid from Iron Man 3 and it's widely
believed that he will go on to become
iron lad now of course he's not
Nathaniel Richards but it's the MCU
they're not going to go on to copy the
comics in its entirety we haven't seen
Harley keiner since Iron Man 3 but it's
widely believed that he was put in there
for a very specific reason because he's
going to eventually become iron lad and
it makes perfect sense because Tony
Stark basically set him up to become
iron lad so if we take a look at
everything that Marvel Studios has given
us from what Tony Stark said in Avengers
in Game two Avengers in games setting up
multiple different timelines and
alternate realities to Harley Keene are
being set up to be iron lad and from the
time variants Authority being set up in
the Loki series it definitely seems like
there's a lot of groundwork being laid
for the introduction of Kang the
Conqueror to the MCU and according to
Mikey Sutton Marvel Studios is planning
on him being the next villain uniting
the Avengers with the Fantastic Four
which makes perfect sense as Kang has
had dealings with both of those teams so
are you excited for Kang the Conqueror
to make his MCU debut let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below don't forget to give the
video a like and subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof